>> EXCUSES, DEFLECTIONS POURING
OUT OF THE TRUMP WOR SINCE
THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH CLAIMING
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE HAPPILY
HANDED OVER THE DOCUMENTS IF
ASKED.
BASICALLY SAYING THE FBI
PLANTED OBVIOUS ALTHOUGH THE
DOCUMENTS HAD ALREADY BEEN
DECLASSIFIED.
BUT THE SHIFTING EXCUSES SHOW
HOW WORRIED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S.
LOTS OF QUESTIONS.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS
DONALD TRUMP'S FORMER FIXER, I
KNOW YOU LIKE THAT, MICHAEL
COHEN, HE IS NOW THE HOST OF A
PODCAST AND AUTHOR OF THE
UPCOMING BOOK, REVENGE, HOW
DONALD TRUMP WEAPONIZE THE U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AGAINST
HIS CRITICS.
MICHAEL, GOOD TO SEE.
YOU >> GET TO SEE YOU, DON.
>> LISTEN, WHAT A WEEK TO TAKE
OFF.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES
ARE REALLY FLOODING THE ZONE
WITH DIFFERENT EXPLANATIONS TO
WHY SO MANY TOP SECRET
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND IN
MAR-A-LAGO.
IS THE TRUMP PLAYBOOK OVER ON
THE STORY OF DESTRUCTION AND
DEFLECTION?
>> WHERE DONALD TRUMP AS I'VE
ALWAYS CALLED, HIM IT'S KEPT IN
CHAOS, IT'S TO THROW AS MUCH TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT HE CAN
IN ORDER TO CONFUSE THEM.
BECAUSE HE TRULY BELIEVES THAT
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC HAS A TWO
DAY, MAYBE IF YOU'RE RIGHT, A
THREE-DAY WINDOW OF REMEMBERING
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
SO HE'LL JUST KEEP FLOODING IT.
BUT THAT'S WHY --
NOT WHY DONALD TRUMP IS DOING
IT.
HE'S SCARED, HE'S SCARED OF THE
DOCUMENTS THAT THEY NOW HAVE
POSSESSION AND CONTROL OVER
BECAUSE THIS IS DOCUMENTARY OF
EVIDENCE, THIS IS EVIDENCE THAT
COULD BE USED AGAINST HIM.
>> YOU SAY WITH THE WALLS ARE
CLOSING IN AROUND HIM, AND HIS
NEXT MOVE IS TO FIND A
SCAPEGOAT.
>> YES, I BELIEVE THAT --
>> BECAUSE YOU WERE A
SCAPEGOAT.
>> YES, AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I TALK A LOT ABOUT IN
REVENGE.
I TAKE YOU FROM THE BEGINNING,
WHERE HE [INAUDIBLE]
ALL THE WAY TO THE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL REMAINED.
BUT I BELIEVE THE NEXT
SCAPEGOAT IS GOING TO BE RUDY
GIULIANI.
I BELIEVE --
EVERYBODY LIKES A COULD
BARGAIN.
DONALD TRUMP LIKES A BARGAIN.
AND I BELIEVE THAT RUDY IS LIKE
A BUG, A BUY ONE GET ONE HALF
OF.
THEY'RE GONNA THROW HIM UNDER
THE BUS FOR MAR-A-LAGO, AND AT
THE SAME TIME THEY'RE GONNA
FROM UNDER THE BUS FOR GEORGIA,
FOR FANI WILLIS'S CASE IN
GEORGIA.
THEY'RE GONNA KEEP POINTING THE
FINGER.
IT'S RUDY, IT'S RUDY.
JUST ASK RUDY.
IT'S RUDY.
>> IT'S SURPRISING, I SHOULDN'T
BE SURPRISED, BUT TO WATCH
EVERYONE MAKE ALL THESE EXCUSES
FOR WHAT HAPPENED, AND EVEN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, BECAUSE THESE
EXCUSES ARE STARTING TO MUDDY
EACH OTHER NOW.
LIKE, WAIT A MINUTE, DID YOU
JUST SAY IT WAS SOMETHING ELSE,
AND YOU'RE SAYING IT'S
SOMETHING ELSE AND SOMEONE IS
GOING UP ON TELEVISION, ONE OF
YOUR PEOPLE SAYING, IT'S NOW
THIS?
ISN'T THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
--
YOU DID SOMETHING WRONG.
YOU JUST DON'T PACK 33 BOXES OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION BY
ACCIDENT.
THAT JUST DOESN'T HAPPEN.
>> NO, NOT ONLY DOES THAT NOT
HAPPEN, HE ALREADY RETURNED
MORE THAN A DOZEN BOXES AND
THEY SIGNED A DOCUMENT STATING
THAT THERE WERE NO MORE BOXES
OF INFORMATION AT MAR-A-LAGO,
WHICH IS OF COURSE ANOTHER LIE.
BUT FOR SO NUMB TO THE LIES
THAT DONALD HAS TOLD US THAT NO
ONE IS EVEN THINKING ABOUT,
YEAH, HE JUST MADE ANOTHER
MISTAKE.
THIS IS CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
AND HE DOES NOT HAVE THE RIGHT
TO TAKE IT, AND AT THE SAME
TIME, HE DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
THE RIGHT --
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
POSSESS THEM.
AND THE REAL QUESTION THAT I
CONSTANTLY BRING UP IS NOT
WHAT'S WHERE THE DOCUMENTS,
IT'S WHY DID HE HAVE THEM IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
AND I BELIEVE IT'S FOR
NEFARIOUS REASONS.
I BELIEVE HE WAS GONNA USE IT
AS A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD
FOR THE GOVERNMENT, YOU COME
AFTER, ME YOU PUT ME IN CUFFS,
YOU PUT ME IN A WHOLE
CONFINEMENT AND INCARCERATION?
ONE OF MY LOYAL SUPPORTERS IS
GOING TO RELEASE TO THE WORLD
WHERE MY NEW CLEARANCE IT --
>> THAT'S SPECULATION ON YOUR
PART.
>> THAT IS, BUT IT'S IN THE
PLAYBOOK.
>> BUT YOU DID PREDICT A LOT OF
THIS.
IN SAYING THAT, IT'S
INTERESTING, BECAUSE PEOPLE
REALLY GET UPSET WITH ME WHEN I
SAY, OF COURSE DONALD TRUMP,
ANYONE SHOULD FACE TOP
CONSEQUENCES --
BUT NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
MERRICK GARLAND, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, SAID THAT AS WELL.
BUT OUR PRESIDENT IS ABOVE THE
LAW.
YOU CAN'T PUT --
I'M JUST --
YOU CAN'T PUT A FORMER
PRESIDENT IN JAIL.
YOU CANNOT PUT HIM IN
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
AND I BELIEVE THEY WILL PUT HIM
IN A HOME CONFINEMENT SITUATION
THAT IS SO SEVERE THAT IT WILL
BE --
ESPECIALLY FOR HIM --
IT WILL BE LIKE SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
>> OKAY, AGAIN.
YOU ARE SPECULATING.
BUT IT'S TOUGH TO PUT FORMER
PRESIDENT IN JAIL, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT KNOWS ABOUT THE
NUCLEAR ARSENALS, HE KNOWS
ABOUT ALL KINDS OF INFORMATION,
INFORMATION THAT IS IN THOSE
TOP SECRET FILES.
>> AND HE WOULD SELL IT TO
ANYBODY AND PRISON FOR A BAG OF
TUNA.
>> AGAIN, THOSE ARE YOUR WORDS.
>> THEY ARE MY WORDS.
>> SO LISTEN TO THIS NEW YORK
TIMES REPORTING TONIGHT THAT
THE --
WEISSELBERG IS CLOSE TO MAKING
A PLEA DEAL AND COULD SERVE
FIVE MONTHS IN PRISON.
HE IS NOT EXPECTED TO COOPERATE
WITH ANY OTHER INVESTIGATION.
TRUMP HAS BEEN FURIOUS BECAUSE
YOU DID NOT WRITTEN MAINE AS
LOYAL TO HIM AS HE WANTED YOU
TO.
ITS LOYALTY TO WET AND?
>> WHAT BOTHERS ME IS THAT I
CAUGHT A SENTENCE OF 36 MONTHS.
BUT THEN AGAIN, WE TALK ABOUT
THE DUST JUNCTION BETWEEN THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK
AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
THE JUDGES IN THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, THEY ARE
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THE JUDGES
AT THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT --
THE FEDERAL COURT JUDGES.
IN THE FACT THAT, THEY REALLY
DO GET DOWN INTO THE MUD WITH
THESE PLEA DEALS.
AND FOR ALLEN TO ONLY END UP
WITH FIVE MONTHS WHEN THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT HE DIDN'T
PAY TAXES ON WAS GREATER, IN
FACT THAN WHAT I DIDN'T PAY,
AND ON TOP OF THAT, HE REFUSES
TO COOPERATE --
I PROVIDED OVER 800 HOURS OF
COOPERATION.
I'VE OPENED UP MORE THAN A
DOZEN INVESTIGATIONS.
>> TWO THINGS, WHY DO PEOPLE
REMAIN LOYAL TO HIM?
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE STUPID.
THERE'S NO OTHER ANSWER TO
THAT.
THEY'RE STUPID.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
THINKING, WHY THEY'RE THINKING,
WHAT IT IS THEY ARE THINKING,
BUT THEY ARE, AND THEY THINK HE
IS GOING TO COME TO THE RESCUE
IN THE END.
NO, THAT IS NOT WHAT HAPPENS.
HE POINTS THE FINGER, AND HE
USES --
ITS ALYN, IT'S MICHAEL, IT'S
RUDY, HE'LL THROW HIS OWN KIDS
UNDER THE BUS BEFORE HIMSELF.
>> CONSIDERING WHAT YOU WENT
THROUGH WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
PRESIDENTS ARE ABOVE THE LAW?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> THANK YOU, MICHAEL COHEN.